Today’s protagonist was born as a Prince
in a southern Indian kingdom, but he soon
discarded his palace life to embrace the study
of Buddhism.
As a travelling Master, he journeyed to China,
where he gained powerful disciples and founded
Dhyana Buddhism, better known in China as
Chan, and later in Japan as Zen.
He is also credited as the first Kung Fu Master
at the Temple of Shaolin.
He popularised meditation, introduced green
tea to China, and had a curious second life
as a popular Japanese doll.
Put the kettle on the stove, control your
breathing, and sink into the life and legend
of Bodhidharma, known as Da Mo in China and
Daruma in Japan.
Here is the life and legacy of the 28th Buddha:
The Prince of Pallava
Most of what we know about Bodhidharma is
painted in the colours of legend; however,
there is a historical account of his life
written by the Chinese monk Daoxuan in the
7th Century AD.
Bodhidharma’s exact date of birth is not
known.
We do know that he was active throughout the
first half of the 6th Century AD and was born
in the South Indian Kingdom of Pallava, corresponding
to the present-day States of Tamil Nadu, Karnataka,
and Andhra Telangana.
At birth he was called Bodhyottara, and he
wasn’t exactly just another citizen of Pallava
-- he was a Royal Prince, the third and youngest
son of King Simhavarman II.
The capital city of Pallava was a placed called
Kanchi, and it was a prominent centre of Buddhist
scholarship, giving birth to many masters
of the Mahayana strand of Buddhism.
The King himself was interested in the Dharma,
a term which indicates the words of the Buddha,
the practice of his teaching, and the attainment
of enlightenment.
That is why he arranged for he and his sons
to be trained by the famed master Prajnottara.
Prajnottara was the 27th in a lineage of masters
and disciples that could be traced back directly
to Siddhartha Gautama, known simply as the
Buddha, the famous founder of the religion.
During the course of the training, the master
noticed the spiritual potential and wisdom
of the youngest prince, but he decided to
wait before making of Bodhyottara his chosen
disciple.
The time was finally ripe when the King died.
While everyone was in mourning, Bodhyottara
remained in a state of deep, constant meditation
for seven consecutive days.
After finally rising a full week later, he
went to Prajnottara and requested to be accepted
as his disciple.
Prajnottara took him under his wing and imparted
all the necessary teachings to make of him
a new master.
Under the guidance of his mentor, Bodhyottara
deepened his understanding of the Dharma,
but also mastered Ayurvedic medicine, acupressure
and martial arts.
When he eventually became bodhi or ‘awakened’,
Prajnottara gave him his new name: Bodhidharma.
He had now become the 28th in that unbroken
lineage of realized Masters.
Buddhism in (about) 3 minutes
I expect that by now your water has boiled.
As your green tea brews for the three minutes
required for the perfect cup, let me give
you a quick summary of the main tenets of
Buddhism.
Buddhism is a religion based on the teachings
of Siddhartha Gautama, born in the 5th century
BC in modern-day Nepal.
He was known by his title "the Buddha," meaning
"the awakened one," after he experienced a
profound realization about the nature of life,
death, and existence.
The Buddha travelled and taught throughout
his life, but he didn't teach people what
he had begun to understand when he became
awakened.
Instead, he taught people how to realize this
awakening for themselves, which would arrive
through their own direct experience, rather
than beliefs and dogmas.
He wasn’t offering an answer; he was teaching
his pupils how to ask the right question.
By the 3rd century BC, Buddhism had become
state religion in India, and from there it
spread throughout the rest of Asia.
Today, the number of Buddhists is estimated
to be about 350 million, which makes Buddhism
the fourth largest religion in the world … although
it is questioned whether it should be considered
a religion at all.
Buddhism is non-theistic at its core and coexists
well with other established religions.
As a result, some scholars choose to consider
it as more of a philosophical doctrine than
an explicit religion.
Nomenclature aside, the detail that sets Buddhism
apart from other religions is the lack of
dogmatic truths to be memorized and believed.
The Buddha taught his followers how to realize
truth for yourself, so its focus is on practice,
rather than belief.
In spite of this emphasis on free inquiry,
Buddhism does provide some explicit beliefs,
known as the Four Noble Truths:
The truth of suffering, or "dukkha"
The truth of the cause of suffering, or "samudaya"
The truth of the end of suffering, or "nirhodha"
The truth of the path that frees us from suffering,
or "magga"
Practitioners are encouraged to explore the
teachings that shape these truths and test
them against their own experience.
And while these truths have been consistent
across time, about 2,000 years ago Buddhism
divided into two major schools: Theravada
and Mahayana, which I mentioned earlier, and
is the school to which Bodhidharma adhered
to.
The two schools differ in their understanding
of the concept of "anatta."
Buddhists believe there is no "self" in the
sense of a permanent, integral, autonomous
being within an individual existence.
The Theravada school considers anatta to mean
that an individual's ego or personality is
a delusion.
Once freed of this delusion, the individual
can enjoy the blissful state of Nirvana.
Mahayana Buddhism goes further, considering
all conscious phenomena as void of intrinsic
identity.
They craft identity only in relation to other
phenomena.
The implication is that there is neither reality
nor unreality, only relativity.
This teaching is called "shunyata," or "emptiness."
Another defining aspect of Mahayana is the
‘Buddha Nature’.
This is a fundamental nature accessible to
all beings, which offers the potential to
reach the awakening, or enlightenment, through
practice.
According to 13th Century Japanese Monk Eihei
Dogen, enlightenment is intrinsic to the Buddha
nature.
Therefore, all beings are already enlightened,
but we need to clarify the nature of our existence
to experience the awakening that was always
there.
And with that, it’s time to sip your tea,
while I continue with our story.
The Emperor and the General
After completing his training, Bodhidharma
was instructed by Prajnottara to travel to
China and impart the teachings of Mahayana.
Upon arriving, Bodhidharma felt that people
were too focused on the conventions of Buddhism,
rather than its essence.
They were too preoccupied with building temples
and chanting, rather than looking into their
own minds for spiritual growth.
Some time after arriving, Bodhidharma was
invited to a monastery to deliver a lesson
to a large number of students, but the Master
just sat in front of them, meditating.
Hours passed by, with Bodhidharma ever undisturbed
by the whispers and murmurs of an impatient
assembly.
Eventually, he just silently stood up and
walked away.
Had he gone crazy?
Was there a mystical meaning behind his silence?
His simple intent was to shock them, to get
students to consider abandoning the pursuit
of the exterior trappings of Buddhism.
To focus on a journey toward the realization
of ‘shunyata’, emptiness, through the
means of meditation: Dhyana in Sanskrit, or
Chan in Chinese.
The news of these teaching methods reached
Emperor Wu of Southern China, an avid practitioner
of Mahayana Buddhism.
He supported the monastic orders generously,
built many Temples, promoted vegetarianism
and banned the sacrifice of animals and capital
punishment.
Believing he had earned an audience with a
wise master like Bodhidharma, Wu summoned
the Indian master to his court and recounted
his own great deeds.
He then asked,
“Having done all these, how much merit do
I have?”.
Bodhidharma replied:
“None”.
The Emperor was taken aback by this answer
and pressed on:
“What is the first principle of the holy
teachings?”
Bodhidharma replied:
“Vast emptiness, nothing holy.”
Bewildered, the Emperor continued:
“Who is standing before me then?”
Bodhidharma replied:
“I don’t know”.
This conversation may have never happened,
but it is one of the first recorded Koans
-- paradoxical anecdotes or riddles, used
in Zen Buddhism to invite deep introspection.
The meaning of this koan is to undermine the
idea of identity and holiness.
The Emperor is portrayed as performing good
deeds, but these are just meant to reinforce
his ego, to use a modern concept.
A king who clings to his ego will never find
the bliss of Nirvana, or the freedom of liberation.
For the second question of the Emperor, the
Master’s response points out that there
is nothing to cling to as ‘holy’.
Everything is inherently holy.
Trying to differentiate between ‘holy’
and ‘unholy’ is quintessentially unholy.
And the third response shatters again the
concept of ego, this time for Bodhidharma
himself.
As his thoughts are passing through him like
water in a river, nothing stays as the true
Bodhidharma.
Self-image is only a mirage.
The story goes that Wu did not fully comprehend
Bodhidharma’s teachings, and continued on
without a true sense of understanding.
Only later did he realise the depth of Bodhidharma’s
message, and he lamented:
‘Alas!
I saw him without seeing him; I met him without
meeting him; I encountered him without encountering
him; Now, as before, I regret this deeply!’
Bodhidharma continued his journey to the city
of Nanjing, on the Yangtse River.
There, he came across a large crowd rallied
around a famous Buddhist monk, Shen Guang,
who happened to be a former warrior, a General,
and one who had not entirely lost his taste
for aggression.
Bodhidharma sat down to listen to Shen Guang,
but his constant nodding irritated the ex-soldier.
Eventually, Shen Guang raised his rosary of
heavy beads and hit Bodhidharma in the face,
out of frustration.
The blow knocked out two of Bodhidharma’s
teeth … but the Master just smiled and walked
away.
Shen Guang was intrigued by this reaction
and immediately started following the Indian
master.
When he reached the banks of the Yangtse River,
he was startled by the sight of Bodhidharma
gently gliding through the water, standing
on a single reed, as if completely weightless.
Well, he could do that, too, couldn’t he?
Seeing an old lady sitting with a bundle of
reeds on the bank, Shen Guang snatched two
reeds off her, tossed them on the river and
jumped on them.
Naturally, he drowned.
Well, almost, as the old lady kind enough
to pull him out of the water.
As Shen Guang’s anger boiled over, he realised
that the man he was following may have been
trying to teach him a lesson, literally.
He had acted out of aggression and mindlessness,
without considering for a second that Bodhidharma
may have been able to sail on a single reed
by virtue of his mindfulness.
Shen Guang had been dragged down into the
water by the weight of his physical body,
as well as the weight of his own self.
The former General had run after Bodhidharma
out of curiosity, but now all he wanted was
to really know the man.
He wished to become his disciple.
The Masters of Shaolin
Bodhidharma continued his journey, and around
the year 527 AD he finally reached his destination:
The Temple of Shaolin, one of the major centres
of Buddhism in China, founded by another Indian
master, Buddhab hadra, in 495 AD.
The Shaolin monks had heard of his approach
and were gathered to meet him.
When they invited Bodhidharma to come stay
at the temple, though, he did not reply.
Instead, he walked to a nearby cave on a mountain
behind Shaolin, sat down, and began meditating.
Here, the stories tell us that the Indian
master sat facing a cave wall and meditated
for nine consecutive years.
According to one story, his concentration
was so intense that the image of his body
was engraved into the stone of the wall before
him.
According to another account, his stillness
was so unbroken that all four limbs eventually
withered and fell off.
Other legends claim that Bodhidharma was unable
to stay fully awake during his nine years
of meditation.
Out of frustration, he pulled out a knife
and proceeded to cut off his eyelids.
As the two scraps of skin fell on the ground,
a tea leaf sprouted on the very spot, the
first to ever grow in China.
But for now, I am going to stick to an account
in which the Master’s body remained intact
inside the cave.
In the meanwhile, Shen Guang had caught up
with him.
Unable to get a word out of Bodhidharma, the
Chinese monk decided to stay outside the cave
and stand guard.
Every so often, both Shen Guang and the Shaolin
monks would try and interact with Bodhidharma,
but no one ever received a reaction.
Finally, after nine years had passed, the
puzzled monks decided that they had to do
something for the enigmatic Master.
So, they built a special room inside the Temple,
just for him.
The Shaolin monks invited Bodhidharma to come
and stay in the room, to which he did not
immediately respond.
Instead, he stood up, walked down to the room,
sat down, and immediately began meditating.
For another four years!
Shen Guang had been standing guard now for
a total of 13 winters.
All his requests to be taught by Bodhidharma
had been ignored.
In a fit of frustration, Shen Guang picked
a large block of snow and ice and hurled it
into the Master’s room.
This massive snowball had the intended effect
of awaking Bodhidharma from his meditation.
Shen Guang demanded to know, once again, when
he would teach him.
The reply he received?
‘When red snow will fall from the sky’
Something inside Shen Guang snapped and he
knew immediately what to do.
As a former warrior, he always carried a sword
with him.
He raised it high above his head and swung
it downwards in a fast, powerful, cutting
motion.
He had just cut off his own left arm.
Shen Guang grabbed his severed limb, raised
it above his head and whirled it around.
The blood still gushing from the left arm
froze in mid-air and floated to the ground
like red snow.
Seeing this act of self-sacrifice, Bodhidharma
agreed to teach Shen Guang.
Their subsequent conversation became another
founding Koan of Zen.
Shen Guang beseeched the Master:
“My mind has no peace yet!
I beg you, O Master, please put it to rest!”
Bodhidharma said
“Bring your mind here and I will pacify
it”
Shen Guang searched for a while, then responded:
“I have searched for my mind, and I cannot
take hold of it.”
Then Bodhidharma declared, “Now your mind
is pacified.”
The next lesson from Bodhidharma would require
four more years of Shen Guang’s life.
Over that span, Bodhidharma asked him to live
on top of Drum Mountain, in front of the Shaolin
Temple.
At the beginning of each year, the Master
would dig up a well, to provide for all of
Shen Guang’s needs.
Each year, the water from the Master’s wells
had a different taste: first bitter, then
spicy, next: sour and finally: sweet.
At this point, Shen Guang realized that the
four wells represented his life.
Like the wells, his life would sometimes be
bitter, sometimes sour, sometimes spicy and
sometimes sweet.
Each of these phases in his life was equally
beautiful and necessary, just as each of the
four seasons of the year is beautiful and
necessary in its own way.
Bodhidharma had imparted this lesson almost
without using any words, a type of “action
language” that is fundamental to Chan, or
Zen, Buddhism.
After this final ordeal and realization, Shen
Guang was given the name Hui Ke by his master,
and he became the abbot of Shaolin after Bodhidharma.
To pay respect for the sacrifice which Hui
Ke made, disciples and monks of the Shaolin
Temple greet each other using only their right
hand.
Zen and the Martial Arts
As I mentioned earlier, most of Bodhidharma’s
life has been mystified by legend.
But assuming what you heard is all fact, you
may be wondering: While Shen Guang was barely
surviving on water at the top of Drum Mountain,
what was Bodhidharma up to?
We can assume it was during this four-year
period that he shared his teachings with the
Shaolin monks.
According to some traditional accounts, he
may have taught them how to fight.
The Chinese martial arts, collectively known
in the West as Kung Fu, may have been first
introduced in the Country by an Indian wandering
monk.
Could this be true?
Well, as a Royal Prince, the young Bodhidharma
may have been already skilled the traditional
Indian martial arts, such as Kalaripaiattu.
Moreover, he received additional training
from his Buddhist master Prajnottara.
And some artwork at the Shaolin depicts a
dark-skinned monk training lighter skinned
students in a variety of hand-to-hand techniques.
However, the predominant point of view among
current Zen scholars is that the claim that
Bodhidharma invented Kung Fu is wildly exaggerated.
For one thing, the first codified Chinese
martial art, Jiao-di, pre-dates the Indian
master by at least 30 centuries.
And while there is a record of Bodhidharma
teaching some physical exercises to the monks,
these are not necessarily related to combat.
The exercises known as the “18 hands of
Lohan” were intended to build up the monks’
Qi, or vital energy, to improve their general
health and nourish their brains – a necessary
step to attain awakening.
Some scholars may argue that a more realistic
interpretation of Bodhidharma’s time at
Shaolin is that he perfected and taught his
new branch of Buddhism, Chan or Zen.
Now I guess it’s time for me to explain
what Zen Buddhism is about.
Bodhidharma himself defined Zen as:
"A special transmission outside the scriptures;
No dependence on words and letters;
Direct pointing to the mind of man;
Seeing into one's nature and attaining Buddhahood."
In other words, Zen requires a face-to-face
transmission of Buddhist precepts, from teacher
to student, outside the written tradition.
And to do that, you need a proper certified
Zen teacher, which I am not.
I can only add that Zen is not an intellectual
discipline you can learn from books, or a
video.
Instead, it's a practice of studying the mind
and seeing into one's nature.
According to Bodhidharma, the main tool of
this is the practice of meditation, best known
from its Japanese name: zazen.
Beginners approaching zazen are taught to
work with their breath to learn concentration.
After a few months, your ability to concentrate
may have ripened.
As you progress, you may understand that the
true goal of zazen … is that there should
not be any goal, nor expectation to a particular
meditation session.
Practitioners should learn to ‘just sit’
in meditation – shikantaza – while learning
a lot about themselves along the way.
Daruma
Bodhidharma’s lofty teaching in Shaolin
and China had won him a few disciples, but
also some powerful enemies, and we are told
that he was eventually poisoned by two rivals.
Allegedly, the sage survived both attempts.
Eventually, during the third attempt, Bodhidharma
accepted to take the poison and died at the
reported age of 150.
But was death the end?
Three years after his death, a Chinese diplomat
named Sòng Yún was returning to China from
a trip to the West when he met none other
than Bodhidharma.
He was on his way back to India, walking barefoot
and carrying one shoe in his hand.
When the diplomat finally got home, and told
this story, the master’s grave was opened.
Inside, it was empty, except for one shoe.
Another version of Bodhidharma’s last years
on Earth tells of how the master left China
for Japan, where he, disguised as a beggar,
met with Prince Shōtoku Taishi, celebrated
as the first great patron of Buddhism in Japan.
While Bodhidharma’s travels to Japan are
strongly disputed, it is a fact that his teachings
did gain great popularity there.
The master became known as Daruma, and his
appearance and story inspired one of the most
popular symbols of Japanese folklore, the
Daruma doll, popular with locals and tourists
alike.
If you have visited Japan, you may have taken
home one of these, wondering what’s the
reason behind the round shape and the blank,
white eyes.
The shape of these dolls reflects the nine
years that Daruma spent meditating in the
cave near Shaolin.
Remember?
His immobility was such that all his limbs
had fallen off.
The wide-opened eyes of the doll remind us
of how the master had cut off his eyelids
to remain awake during zazen.
The dolls are normally made without their
pupils, it is up to their owners to draw them
once their wishes are fulfilled.
Over time, the doll took a life of its own,
collecting attributes further and further
removed from the original inspiration.
For example, it was dressed in red, a colour
associated with measles and smallpox, and
became a talisman to protect children against
these diseases.
In a surprising twist, artists of the Edo
era (1603 to 1868) even morphed these dolls
into phallic symbols.
The sexual attributes were then shifted onto
the sage himself, who became the object of
parody-filled illustrations in which he leers
at prostitutes or courtesans.
What a strange, worldly tribute to the man
who once said
“To have a body is to suffer”
I hope you learned something new from today’s
video … and I hope that what you learned
is that you can’t really learn anything
by reading a book or watching
a video.